Another important role during a review meeting is that of the recorder.
The recorder is responsible for making a record of the issues raised during
a review. Note that it may not be possible to determine in a review meeting
itself whether an issue represents a defect. This determination may
require some offline research. It is the job of the recorder to proactively
clarify the issues raised. During the course of a heated, heated discussion,
this may be difficult. Several different issues may intertwine more of
a two seemingly different concerns may actually reflect a common question.
The recorder will often ask for clarification until he is satisfied that he
understands the essence of the problem being discussed.